dinah rectly presumably you are familiar
with Miriam's potty mouth because are
you because you ran high water but did
you actually work together yeah yeah but
I don't know I've been told there was a
swear jar involved on set but I can't
remember that I don't you remember you
swearing a lot of money I was probably
careful when it was you but when you
know with the other kids I didn't boss
just talking backstage if that's what
you call that funny little apparently
it's 20 years since Harry Potter came
out there since we started filming the
first one and your balls have dropped
since
[Applause]
they're just weak kids think we get it
yes
[Applause]
yeah but it's interesting because
professor sprouts which you know you're
in the second film of the last room yeah
I should have been in all of them yes
that was a grave oversight oh I'm
holding you responsible
anyway it was wonderful to be in the two
that I was in and I'm very proud of it
but you do get recognized as Professor
spray I do
I mean I think I've changed since then
but people do recognize me and funnily
enough in Lithuania have you come just
to see professor sprout other films
called professors for after the Gypsy
but I was mobbed in Lithuania maybe
because I was Jewish I don't know the
only one
I just think that's incredible like
you've been marbled Alania and you
professor sprout imagine being this I
know what what was it like I mean it's
weird and funny and I think I the best
way to see it always was like weird and
funny because it will you know and it
abscent flows and sometimes it's in your
life a lot and sometimes it's not in
terms of getting recognized and there's
been lots of very odd moments was chased
out of a science museum in Spain so the
point cuz everything was in Spanish
there I couldn't understand anything
inside so I was trying to leave anyway
but someone thought you were something
else in New York recently oh yeah you
know this did not come up in in with it
yeah so so me my girlfriend fostered a
dog and it we sort of got our friends to
adopt it this is not necessary for the
story there's a dog with me I I was on
the street with this dog and my
girlfriend was in the shop and so I
would say it was very cold
I've got my hoodie and my fleece my
fleece hoodie and and then a big coat
over that and the dog was really cold so
just kneel by you and like stroke you
enjoyed try and keep you warm and then
and then I saw this guy like look off of
me like 10 yards away and smile and I
was like yeah and just carried on then
he walked past me and he came back like
got about five steps past me then just
reappeared with a five dollar bill over
my shoulder and then gaze of a coffee
mate
like my girl thinking I was I don't
think I'm Brett I'm going I'm wearing
nice clothes I thought yes I was very
much that was a wake-up call I'm Hani I
have to maybe you know I do maintain cuz
the person that owns the dog has also
been mistaken for a homeless person with
this dog I think the dog looks very cold
and sweet and vulnerable a sir encounter
only a few weeks ago in Los Angeles
rather fancy in fact extremely fancy
restaurant tell them what it is they'll
know it was the the tower bar I know
[Applause]
you keep going I got a feeling this
isn't gonna work out so we're the four
of us were seated at a table about 15
minutes later into the restaurant walks
Sir Paul McCartney Wow good smell Oh
Paul and I have a very slender
relationship but it's lasted decades
encountered him in 1964 no when his
girlfriend Jane Asha then had told him
that I loved Aston Martin's I was
driving a battered old Ford but Aston
Martin's were my dream car
she told him this and one night yeah we
knew he was seeing the show there was a
knock on my door and I said yeah come in
I'm there in my underwear
no like as usual
[Laughter]
I'm ready for you
and the door opened standing there was
Paul McCartney who I had never met
before and this was 1964 he said J says
that you like Aston Martin's here drive
this and he tossed a bunch of keys and
it was ass we're now in the tower Baro
[Applause]
I'm feeling less he sees me and comes
over and I stand up say hi and we have a
big hug in the restaurant and I'm very
much aware that there's all the tables
are full on this kind of thing and we
talked for five or six minutes and he
goes and sits down five minutes go by
and into the restaurant
walks sir Ringo Starr I swear to you
they were there were oh they were at the
same table they were the same yes well
we've at the tower free meal
we finish early and I get up to go and
Paul stands up to say goodbye and we
have a hug and this we have a hug he
says into my ear do you know Ringo I've
never met him but I'm Ringo come on come
over here hang on a minute he said sir
Ringo sir Patrick Sir Paul hey we've got
the knights of the round table
[Applause]
you notice something about British
people and the way they speak that we do
a funny thing no I mean I love all the
every regional accent every time you're
not gonna give you that scar man but I
like that because there's so many
accents to such a small country
everybody sort of puts on different
voices when they're doing a little bit
so yeah yeah but I had a thing where I
was checking into a hotel and somebody
came out and said oh dude you'd help
with you bugs and I've I thought they
were doing a bit
I had to like slowly transition out of
it no that that sounds like an
exaggeration of their voice but then I
was back in the country several years
later and they were on TV on goggle box
because it was deaf and dumb from so
they actually talk like that I never
knew that that was a real hotel yeah you
say there have experienced officious
animals you what creature no I feel like
I've had a lot of professional dealings
with animals I did a film I did a film
with a lion once I just shoot with a
with a lion you know a wild lion and why
I say wild I mean he's been in films and
we had to do her I arrived to shoot this
scene and I the first thing I noticed
with the camera crew were in a steel
cage only big enough to contain the
camera I thought I'd better ask some
basic safety questions I said what is
what is the sort of safety thing here
with this wild lion and they said well
the first thing is we make sure before
the line works we make sure that he has
sex just to take the edge off
and I said well though I'm not
particularly worried about the I'm not
worried about a Randy lion I'm more
worried about the eating kind and they
said that's alright because we will feed
the line we won't feed him too much
because then he'll go to sleep and I
said again that's not really does Ari
know what it's like you open a packet of
crisps do you have one but then you can
and the third thing they said the third
sort of safety measure was that the
Lions downhill and he's very lazy and he
probably won't chase you and again I was
just not really reassured by this and I
said to the chap but what you know what
if it does happen what what are you
supposed to do and he took great delight
that South African handler took great
delight in telling me that if a lion
charges you useful advice you have to
reach back you take a handful of [__]
you throw it in the Lions face and I
obviously said where'd you get the [__]
problem he said don't worry it'll be
there I really really enjoyed get out
and everything you're doing is fantastic
wonderful I made a song for you actually
what do you mean what do you mean oh
it's quick but it's the best I could do
in a short amount of time let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was beautiful you got a thank you
so much I'm just out here auditioning
for everything you know we all do other
jobs we remember starting out and lots
of people do the classic catering David
Schwimmer you went one up from waiting
tables you did waiting tables with a
little bit extra I waited tables for a
long time about seven years but my first
gig was as a rollerskating waiter at
this yeah I was good at this really cool
place in Chicago any cool it was it was
called that's called Edie de Becque
[Applause]
doors that came out of this place
player-character yeah I was Romeo I was
Frankie
[Applause]
only Romeo roller-skated Mazzone well in
Chicago they had rollerskating all right
so and I was roller skates and and then
I was serving all the outdoor tables so
there was a huge parking lot and a
pretty wide sidewalk with tables lined
up like picnic tables where families
would come in and you'd make not very
much money with minimum wage in the
States as you're aware but you made a
lot of money by performing stunts so I
would like line up people's kids and
they would like you know they wouldn't
you know kneel next to each other in a
line I could probably jump over three or
four I'm serious and then I would say
hey you guys want to see it you know the
parents were like yeah go for it
just like I would just take off down the
street and jump all over I mean over
over them and then and then kind of like
skid to a stop and then I'd get you know
all these fancy tips from doing it but
you had to play a character and my
character was like Romeo the romancer
you know he was kind of based a little
on Travolta in you know Greece or
something you know I mean it was a 50s
diner so I had a big pompadour and you
know bigger muscles at the time
this from that time is this when you
were Romi at home I had that earring
that screams Romi yeah no but my hair
was not as long as that it was more of a
pompadour okay yeah similar similar
embarrassing
[Music]